Miles Morales is getting an iron spider
suit and it looks amazing so this is the
conclusion to Carnage Reigns which is
basically the fight between Miles
Morales and Cletus Cassidy who's
normally Carnage but in this story he's
using the extrivia armor basically a
piece of the Carnage symbiote combined
with Iron Man Tech so like we finished
with the last video which you'll find
down in the description below the like
button basically Miles Morales and the
team that he's working with are just
fleeing for their lives because it's the
best they can do against Cletus with
just this level of power I mean the
Symbiote in and of itself is already
immensely capable when you combine it
with Stark Tech now it has energy blasts
and all kinds of stuff so most of this
is just damage control but like we saw
at the end of the last video because of
the fact that the extrembient armor
originated with Iron Man he's literally
been prepping for this he's been waiting
for the time when Cletus Cassidy
re-emerges with this extrimbioed armor
and then starts going on whatever
campaign he's been going on which is why
Iron Man shows up here in what's
basically a giant mech suit which looks
amazing you could call it like the
Symbiote Buster armor right like the
Carnage Buster armor because it is
enough to initially blast Cletus Cassidy
but it's not enough to kill him at the
very least it allows them to buy a
moment to kind of consolidate their
forces and figure out what they're gonna
do next here's the problem with all of
this where Cletus Cassidy is initially
thought to be defeated by Miles Morales
this is his inexperience talking one of
the things to remember is that Cletus
and Carnage have been around for a very
long time and while Cletus Cassidy is
normally the human who uses the Carnage
symbiote the fact remains he's done all
kinds of stuff so Iron Man knows enough
to know that because the extremia suit
is one part Iron Man Tech combined with
the Carnage symbiote which makes Cletus
Cassidy incredibly capable this guy's
not going to be taken out in one shot
but in the middle of all this where it
is kind of a momentary reprieve Miles
Morales is impaled by Cletus so Iron Man
does the only thing he can do he injects
nanites into to the body of Miles
Morales that basically begin the healing
process but in order to do that it
encases him in what initially Iron Man
calls a cast and then says that may not
necessarily be the right term it's
really more of a suit now here's a thing
to understand Miles Morales getting this
iron spider suit is starkly different
from when Peter Parker got it Peter
Parker got it is almost kind of a reward
so to speak for him siding with Iron Man
during Civil War this suit is really
more of necessity right it has healing
components stuff like that Iron Man does
that all the time it's just the nature
of his suit right like life support and
all that kind of stuff and so with Miles
Morales having a whole new host of
abilities in addition to his traditional
Spider-Man Powers one of the things to
keep in mind is that this iron spider
suit in terms of capabilities seems to
very much mirror the suit of Peter
Parker one of the big differences though
is that where Peter Parker's suit had
its own capabilities this one comes with
the ability to enhance the Venom blast
of Miles Morales the electric shock that
he normally dishes out and so the
initial display of Miles along with Iron
Man is to blast Cletus with as much
energy as they possibly have in an
attempt to blow the Symbiote off of him
because what iron man realizes here is
that because the Symbiote is one part
Tech and because the extrimbiote has
basically infected pretty much all the
city of New York there's almost like a
limitless supply of power that the
Symbiote itself can draw on so the best
they can do is blow it off of Cletus and
then try to find a way to keep the two
of them separated which is a chore in
and of itself because Cletus controls
the Symbiote and the Symbiote controls
him right they are both immensely
powerful here and so what is up going on
is Iron Man realizes the only way to
really achieve this is to effectively
detonate an EMP from inside of the
Symbiote itself the tech and the
symmetal go out the Symbiotes control
over Indian All Tech in the city of New
York will go out but to get inside of
that means creating a halt and that's
where he looks to Miles and the rest of
Miles team kind of like these uh
anti-symbiote guys that are normally
villains but are operating as Heroes
that's where he looks to them to create
this opening the problem is the
situations complicated even further
through a combination of Cletus
Cassidy's ability to kind of hijack the
minds of people who were looking at
their phones when the extremia tech was
activated but other people who in fact
are using Iron Man suits now the way
this works is that Cletus was able to
basically steal Iron Man suits and then
send them over to individuals who were
like his most loyal followers crazy
people on Twitter who were tweeting
stuff out where they support him
literally that's what they were doing
right just people on social media who
really really really like him and so
these guys get their own Iron Man suits
combined with symbiotech that almost
makes them comparable to Cletus Cassidy
and so in the midst of all this red
Goblin jumps back into The Fray now we
covered this in the last video red
Goblin is the grandson of the
traditional Green Goblin but the reason
why he matters here is because he has
the ability to absorb symbiote material
so in effect he could just seize control
of these Iron Man suits absorb the
Symbiotes off of them and now they're
just Iron Man suits running around that
these guys would have virtually no power
over it's not that easy to do you and
red Goblin does where he can when he can
but at the end of the day it really is
all just one giant fight against Cletus
and so in essence the group gets split
off into three factions the team that
Miles Morales is working with is just
doing local damage control keeping the
innocent people from like harming
themselves and harming others the red
Goblin is running around trying to pull
the Symbiotes off of these Iron Man
suits and miles and Tony Stark are
focusing on Cletus Cassidy himself each
one of them are successful in their own
way but one of the things that happens
here with Iron Man is he basically
initiates a kind of Sonic Blast which
isn't enough to take out Carnage and not
even enough to separate the Symbiote
from him but it is enough to again push
this guy back at Bay but one of the
things I want you guys to notice here
the best they can do is hold him off
that's the best they can do at this
point in time the level of power that
Cletus has is just so astronomically
high now some of that again is due to
the Iron Man suit as well as the Carnage
symbiote but one of the things to also
remember in the Venom Comics that we're
covering Marvel is leading the power of
the Symbiotes as they exist in Marvel
Comics in previous years they were just
literally organisms that attached to a
house and they could just do some cool
stuff but with everything going on in
Eddie Brock's story it's a whole new
ball game they're a lot more durable and
a lot more powerful than they used to be
this also includes Cletus and so as this
Fight Continues on you have this
statement from Iron Man which is kind of
hilarious where he's like okay we have
to go with the nuclear option and the
response of miles is just like you can't
nuke New York Tony Stark he's like it's
a figure of speech kid but we might also
have to do that too just something to
keep in the back of your head we might
have to Nuke the city
but one of the things that's going on is
Cletus is obviously absorbing different
people around him initially it started
with Kenneth Neely the guy who was
obsessed with Carnage and all that kind
of stuff and it's just been like a
massive Fanboy for Cletus Cassidy ever
since the fact that he's absorbed isn't
overly important here but it's just a
point to the idea that that's why you
see like these different faces that
Cletus is communicating with because
their personalities that he's absorbed
unto himself the other thing going on is
that where red Goblin wasn't able to
pull these extreme suits off of the Iron
Man armor that was being piloted by
these crazy fans Carnage does and so
what Iron Man says is I need you Miles
Morales to buy me like five minutes
while he charges this EMP it's no small
thing and it's a massive amount of
energy and it will take out the entirety
of his suit's power core in order to
pull it off and so miles does exactly
that the issue here is that with Cletus
Cassidy pulling every ounce of extremia
tech around him right that he's put into
the city that he put into the Iron Man
suits and so on and so forth extracting
all of that unto himself he's more
powerful than he was before which means
miles is literally fleeing for his life
he's just playing cat and mouse playing
possum he's just kind of drawing the
attention of Cletus Cassidy from
different places Cletus literally wants
to take off into space go find Carnage
merge with a symbiote and then Slaughter
everything across the universe that he
possibly can but the goal of miles is to
keep him here because if that merger
happens understand if that merger
happens you would be talking about a
version of Carnage with a love of power
that would be virtually unchallenged no
one would be able to stand against him
so the goal here is to keep that from
happening to literally prevent a series
of events taking place where Carnage
would kill the Marvel universe so Miles
Morales holds his own to a degree right
he's just like Tony Stark how much
longer he had gotten Sarge like you're
doing great kid just give me a few more
minutes and he's like you know I don't
feel like I'm doing greatly but you are
which by the way every time I read Miles
Morales in Marvel Comics I hear shamique
more I can't help it now it's just the
way that it is let me know down in the
comments if you do the exact same thing
but it's funny because one of the things
that's kind of drawn on here by miles is
that under any normal circumstance
Cletus would just ignore him and just
leave but Cletus has an ego he wants the
world to see what he's doing it's a
really brilliant Stroke by Cody Ziegler
as the writer because as most of you
guys know or maybe some of you guys know
I'm not really sure when it comes to
serial killers they like an audience
they like the idea of being caught they
want people to know that they're the one
who did it now something else to know
here if he did not have this iron spider
suit he would have been dead a long time
ago but the suit gives him enhanced
speed enhanced durability and and
strength it allows him to dodge out of
attacks so it is the only reason that
he's currently still alive such as it is
Iron Man finally gets the time that he
needs that in this moment when the
entirety of the Venom blast that Miles
has using every ounce of energy his suit
has left when it punches into Cletus
Cassidy it's not enough to take him out
but it is enough to distract him Iron
Man Comes rushing in charges into the
chest of Cletus and detonates the
entirety of the EMP at his disposal
which blows the extremio suit everywhere
it just blows it all over the place and
it takes it off of Cletus Cassidy now
the thing about this is this is when you
get this realization Cletus isn't really
human anymore there's no physical form
of Cletus Cassidy walking around he and
the Symbiote are one and the same this
is the benefit and a drawback it's a
drawback because outside of the Symbiote
itself there is no core Target to hit
but it's a benefit for Cletus Cassidy
because so long as a portion of the
Symbiote survives he will survive as
well well and that's exactly what
happens that where Iron Man's suit is
just completely and totally powered down
running on like minimal power it allows
him to basically look up White Castles
so that they can go and get something to
eat which makes sense because when the
craving hits it hits hard unfortunately
miles also loses the iron spider suit
but don't worry guys he's gonna get it
back this is Marvel testing it this is
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with Comics this is Marvel
testing this out right it's Marvel's
saying let's give miles an iron spider
suit and let's see how fans react to it
we all love it we're all excited about
it he's gonna get it back
somewhere along the line but of course
with Cletus Cassidy surviving all of
this it's only a small portion of
himself a very very small infinitesimal
part but as those of you guys know when
it comes to the Symbiotes all you need
is a drop it can duplicate itself it can
grow back this is basically Cletus
buying his time because ultimately from
what we can tell by the future
solicitations the death of the Venom
verse Carnage traveling across the
Multiverse killing every version of
Venom he can possibly find that's really
going on this Summer that basically the
two of them seem like they're going to
emerge Cletus is going to remerge with
Carnage and we're going to get this
ridiculously op character but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know what you think
about the Carnage rain storyline thank
you all for watching I will catch you
all later
peace